it is hard to make yourself heard when
there are so many others
and they just keep coming
this rescue center is inundated with
dogs needing new homes many like cersei
have been given up
by owners who can no longer afford them
i don't think we really saw that the
cost of living was going to increase we
kind of knew about the lockdown dogs and
people not having the time for them once
things got back to normal the
socializing aspect of dogs during
lockdown so we foresee you know we were
going to get an increase in dogs that
way but the cost of living you know it
has shocked people i think everything's
gone up so that's really tough on
families it's a very hard decision to
make
at christmas the rspca rescued 29
more animals than the previous year in
england and wales and that charity is
expecting to see a further increase by
summer due to the cost of living
crisis at this dog's home the number of
animals they have taken in over the last
year has doubled they are full and as
well as those giving up their
pets they're also struggling here as a
charity with the soaring costs of fuel
and utility bills
the average cost of caring for a small
dog is around 50 pounds a month and that
doesn't include cover if things go wrong
so in terms of insurance there's a wide
range of insurances out there really but
you're probably looking about 50 pounds
a month at least for a good level of
cover with lifetime cover but it's so
worth that security for example if if a
dog ever needs an mri scan we're
probably talking talking two and a half
thousand to three thousand pounds for a
scan alone some orthopedic procedures
again we're talking well into the
thousands of pounds
rising costs mean there are also fewer
people looking to adopt but there will
still be those with room in their budget
for a dog like bear
lisa dowd sky news birmingham dogs home